from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills today we're joined by bloomberg
opinion writer frank berry who is
traveling the country
all the way from new york to san
francisco in an rv
with his wife definitely taking work
from home
on the road and redefining what that
looks like for us all
uh frank thank you so much for making
time to chat with us on your journey
of course happy to do it where where are
you and how are you how are you holding
up
uh we're doing great we've uh we've come
through pennsylvania and ohio
and uh without too many problems in the
rv and the weather's been great so
it's been so far so good we're meeting a
lot of great people along the way and
having some good conversations
that's great and we actually we have a
look at some of those conversations
you've had over the past
week or so so um let's i'm frank barry a
writer with bloomberg opinion and i'm
taking this rv
across the country from new york city to
san francisco along the lincoln highway
this week the road brought us through
trenton new jersey where i met with the
organizer of a graffiti festival
i talked with him about some of the work
that he's done to create a community of
artists this is jersey fresh jam so this
is our 15th
year and you know a lot of people come
from all over and just to celebrate art
and life
[Music]
from there we drove south to
philadelphia where i talked with the
leader of a band called low cut connie
which has become a streaming sensation
in the age of covet
[Music]
from there we drove west to lancaster
pennsylvania and the night we were in
lancaster
there was a fatal police shooting
protesters came downtown
and what started as a peaceful protest
ended with tear gas and rubber bullets
being fired
the next morning i met with people who
were there spoke with them about the
protest
about the changes they want to see not
just in lancaster but across the country
let me ask you a question because i've
been asking a lot of people this
question we've got so much
division so much uh racial injustice
so much anger around it so much
political division
when everyone's so divided what do you
think holds us together
as a country what is it that we what is
it that we share in common as a country
when we've got so much division
along these big issues we are all human
just hope at the end of the day exactly
that we might get
to a better tomorrow but it doesn't it
does it's not going to take just me it
doesn't take one pin it doesn't it takes
all of us
so until we can actually unite that's
when actual change can happen
all right well thank you for taking the
time i appreciate it thank you
and so i'll be posting a weekly update
and if you're interested
please post any comments you have any
questions
and i hope you'll come along for the
journey
[Music]
so frank you are two weeks in you've
done a lot
but i want to just start by talking
about your time in trenton and philly
what are some of the highlights for you
from those trips
rainbow brought together this really
great community of artists who were
there to
paint the walls of this recycling
company and um
we talked a little bit with leon about
the work that he's done in the community
including post george floyd riots about
the painting of the graffiti
work that he's done downtown on boarded
up uh buildings and on some
buildings that had their windows smashed
in uh and um
you know why he did it and you don't
often hear about you know graffiti as a
uh as a way to heal a community and
bring it together but that's what he's
doing and i thought it was pretty
powerful
and can you bring me into that
conversation what are some of the things
that you
talked about that really resonated with
you
frank i'm having trouble hearing you for
some reason i'm so sorry
um but we we are talking with frank
berry as a reminder to our viewers
about his experience traveling the
country he's in an rv
going all the way from new york to san
francisco and i was just asking about
the
graffiti you interviewed frank if we
have sound from you
can you tell us a little bit more about
that
sure uh can you hear me now yes i can
hear you it's perfect
okay so
doing in trenton to try to help the
community heal in the wake of the george
floyd riots through his graffiti and
through this community
of artists that he's brought together
and then from there we went down into
philadelphia
and i met with the leader of a band
called low cut connie
uh and they have really become a
streaming hit uh
in the age of cobin they've built a real
following online and he puts on twice
weekly shows in which he's
putting on this really high energy
performance
and people of all walks of life have
really
uh really gotten into it and he's built
this pretty diverse audience
uh that that is really proud of and that
he's been working
to build for a long time that that
crosses racial and
and all kinds of cultural lines
and it's something that uh is not that
common
in the music industry and i talked with
him about some of the pushback that he's
gotten from the industry
in terms of building that audience and
his commitment to it and
some of the some of the difficulties and
holding together
this diverse fan base uh which includes
lots of uh conservative fans who have
been unhappy with some of the
music that he's done and some of the
things that he's talked about on these
live streams
and moving ahead you had a really kind
of shocking experience in lancaster can
you
tell us what happened while you were
there
sure so when we got to lancaster we
settled in for the night and didn't
realize until the next morning that that
night there was actually a police
shooting
uh downtown and uh it was a police
shooting of a young
man um and
it resulted in protests in front of the
police station
that resulted in the end
with tear gas and rubber bullets being
fired and windows
being smashed at the police department
at the postal
office across the street and at some
local businesses
and so i went down the next morning
to its really quiet streets uh to talk
with some of the people who had been
there about what they saw
and what happened and it sounds like
what started as a peaceful protest grew
out of control
in part because of some people
that i spoke to anyway who said that you
know there were uh
people who were not part of their group
who had really not been part of the
protest that they've been carrying on
since the george floyd
killing and things just got out of
control
but it was another example of um not
just an issue
of a police shooting
but of um of the police response and the
unhappiness with it in terms of the the
use of force
and frank you interviewed multiple uh
constituents in the area about their
experience and i know we played some
sound from that in our video but
uh can you take me into some of those
conversations and what people told you
that they were thinking following that
police thing
i'm sorry master would you mind
repeating that you cut out there yeah of
course no i'm wondering if you can just
tell me a little bit we heard some sound
in that package
about how people reacted to the police
shooting but can you tell me more
about what people told you that their
reactions were
yeah so so people were you know it was
interesting we we ended up talking
less about the shooting than we did
about the police response to it and as
you can imagine
there was uh there have been protests
going on since the george floyd protest
uh the george floyd killing around
i think we might be losing frank so we
are going to give
you all another look at his week you can
find his column
weekly in the bloomberg opinion section
uh but for now let's just give you one
more look at
uh frank's week on the road i'm frank
barry a writer with bloomberg opinion
and i'm taking this rv
across the country from new york city to
san francisco along the lincoln highway
this week the road brought us through
trenton new jersey where i met with the
organizer of a graffiti festival i
talked with him about some of the work
that he's done to create a community of
artists this is jersey fresh jam so this
is our 15th
year and you know a lot of people come
from all over and just to celebrate art
and life
from there we drove south to
philadelphia where i talked with the
leader of a band called low cut connie
which has become a streaming sensation
in the age of covet
[Music]
from there we drove west to lancaster
pennsylvania and the night we were in
lancaster
there was a fatal police shooting
protesters came downtown
and what started as a peaceful protest
ended with tear gas
and rubber bullets being fired the next
morning i met with people who were there
spoke with them about the protest about
the changes they want to see
not just in lancaster but across the
country let me ask you a question
because i've been asking a lot of people
this question we've got so much
division so much racial injustice
so much anger around it so much
political division
when everyone's so divided what do you
think holds us together
as a country what is it that we what is
it that we share in common as a country
when we've got so much division
along these big issues we are all human
just hope exactly that we might get
to a better tomorrow but it doesn't it
does it's not going to take just me it
doesn't take one pin it doesn't it takes
all of us
so until we can actually unite that's
when actual change can happen
all right well thank you for taking the
time i appreciate it thank you
and so i'll be posting a weekly update
and if you're interested
please post any comments you have any
questions and i hope you'll come along
for the journey